[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
رايي تكثف غاراتها على قطاع غزه وتغطى
القياديا في حركه الجهاد وصواريخ الاخيره
تصل تل ابيب
اعداد اعداد هائله من المصابين عادات
كبيره جدا
جراء الصراع العسكري وتفاؤل على صعيد
المحادثات في جده
قبل ثلاثه ايام من بدء الانتخابات انسحاب
مفاجئ لاحد منافسي اردوغان واستطلاع يرجح
انتصار كلجدار اوغلو
المحكمه العليا في باكستان تامر بالافراج
مؤقتا عن عمران خان والحكومه تطالبها
بقرار يدين شغب انصاره
[موسيقى]
الغارات الاسرائيليه على غزه ما تزال
مستمره لا بل قد تتوسع بعمليات اكبر ضد
حركه الجهاد وفقا لتهديدات تل ابيب مقابل
ذلك صواريخ الفصائل تواصل انطلاقها من
القطاع على مناطق متفرقه من اسرائيل
واسقطت لاول مره قتيلا واصابات فتل ابيب
التوتر تصاعد اكثر بعد مقتل احمد ابو دقه
عضو المجلس العسكري لسرايا القدس الجناح
المسلح لحركه الجهاد التي اكدت ان توجه ان
نتوجه وفدا للقاهره او توجه وفد القاهره
لا يعني ضعفا او صعوبه ميدانيه نتنياهو
توعد وقال ان قواته ماتزال في وسط العمليه
العسكريه سواء في الهجوم او الدفاع
[موسيقى]
في وقت سابق من صباح اليوم قمنا باغتيال
قائد مجموعه صواريخ الجهات في غزه والان
منذ فتره وجيزه اختل نائبه ايضا اي شخص
ياتي ليؤذينا لن يجني سوى الدم على راسه
هو ومن يحل محله نحن في منتصف المعركه في
الهجوم والدفاع وسنواصل التقدم لحمايه
سمائنا وحياه مواطننا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من حدود قطاع غزه
زياد حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
زياد عادت الغارات كيف هي الصوره من هناك
لو سمحت
الان هناك رشقات صاروخيه تصل الى منطقه
غلاف غزه الى المستوطنات القريبه من هنا
يعني الان ستكون انفجارات بالقرب منا على
ما اعتقد لان هناك الكثير من الصواريخ
اطلقت في هذه الاتجاهات عمليا راينا
صواريخ تسقط هنا في محيطنا قبل نحو ساعتين
من الان ايا كان هناك قصف نعم الان هناك
عمليا محاوله اعتراض لصواريخ
هل يمكن ان نرى الصوره يا على المقلب
الاخر على ما اعتقد لا لا لا نعم الان من
خلفي من خلفي الان
جيد الان من خلفي
اعلان الصوت
هذه عمليه اعتراض الان لصواريخ فوق
مستوطنه قبل بعض الوقت سقطت
نعم الان الانفجار قبل بعض الوقت اصيب
عمليا الان هناك رشاقات صاروخيه لنتابع
عشرات الصواريخ الان تنطلق
انفجارات في كل مكان تقريبا
الرشقات الصاروخيه التي تصدر الان كانت
متوقعه عند الساعه التاسعه عمليا بتوقيت
فلسطين تسمى عند الجهاد الاسلامي ساعه
البهاء سعد اغتيال بهاء ابو العطا بيدي
اسرائيل الذي كان قائد المنطقه الشماليه
لدى الجهاد الاسلامي قبل سنوات عمليا وهي
ساعه مفضله لاطلاق الصواريخ لدى
حركه الجهاد عاده ولكن بدون ان شك في
الساعتين الاخيرتين هناك تصعيد نوعي في
كميات اطلاق الصواريخ نتحدث عن عشرات
الصواريخ التي اطلقت عمليا تجاه عسقلان
هذا بالاضافه الى الصواريخ السابقه التي
كانت وصلت الى مدينه الحوفوت قربه الابيب
عمليا اصابه مباشره في مبنى وقتيل
اسرائيلي 13 جريحا في تلك المنطقه
بالاضافه الى ذلك اصابه خمسه منازل في
مستوطنه من خلفنا عمليا بصواريخ بالاضافه
الى ذلك سقوط صاروخ على بعد 50 مترا
تقريبا من سياره وزيره الاستيطان اريد
ستروك واحدى الشظايا ضربت يعني اصابه
السياره بينما كانت فيها هذا كانت تطور
ايضا كان ليكون دراماتيكيا الان يجتمع
بنيامين نتنياهو فيروز وزاره الدفاع مع
وزير الدفاع ومستشار الامن القومي الان
هناك صواريخ من فوقنا يمكن ان تروا على
الشاشه
هذا الصاروخ تجاوز القبه الحديديه
عمليا وبالتالي كنت اقول بان نتنياهو الان
مجتمع مع وزير الدفاع ومع مستشار الامن
القومي الاسرائيلي ومع قاده الجيش وقاده
الاجهزه الامنيه هذا الجسم هو من يتخذ
القرارات العمانيه على الارض بمعنى قرارات
التصعيد المتوقع المزيد من محاولات
الاغتيال هذه الليله والتصعيد الاسرائيلي
في مقابل هذا كم الكبير من اطلاق الصواريخ
نتوقع ايضا اطلاق صواريخ ربما حتى اتجاه
تل ابيب مجددا من قبل حركه الجهاد
الاسلامي ان كنا بالامس نتحدث عن ان وقفه
اطلاق النار كان قاب قوسين او ادنى من
تحقيقه اليوم نتحدث عن ان وقف اطلاق النار
ابتعد عمليا لكن هذا لا يعني الكثير حقيقه
في مثل هذه الجولات من التصعيد غدا قد
نفاجئ بان هناك اتفاق وقفه نار وما الى
ذلك رغم هذا التصعيد وكما قلنا في
النهايات هناك تصعيد نوعي في الضربات من
كلا الطرفين كل الطرف يحاول
ان يحقق مشهدا انتصار بين مزدوجين لكي
الوعي والقول انه انجز انجازات كبيره في
هذه الجوله
زياد اذا ممكن ان ننجز مجددا يعني بالامس
كنا نتحدث عن وساطه مصريه
لوقف اطلاق النار بين الطرفين اليوم تعثرت
هذه الوساطه ما الذي حصل وكيف ممكن ان
يتفق الطرفان مجددا على وقف اطلاق النار
نعم فقط ان كنت تذكرين قلت ان بعض
الصواريخ تجاوزت القبه الحديديه الان وصلت
الى ريشون لتسيون عمليا الى وحولون وسط
يعني وسط اسرائيل بالقرب من تل ابيب الان
في هذه الرشقه الصاروخيه الاخيره على
الاقل عدد من الصواريخ وصل الى وسط
اسرائيل الى مدينه حلول وريش
محاولات اعتراض في تلك المنطقه على ما
يصلني يصلني الان وبالتالي الان قرب تل
ابيب سفارات الانذار ما تزال تدوي في هذه
اللحظه كما قلنا الصاروخ يحتاج تقريبا
ثلاث دقائق حتى يصل الى تل ابيب بينما حيث
نحن هنا 15 ثانيه يصل الصاروخ في بعض
الاحيان ويمكن ان يسقط في المنطقه
زياد كنا نتحدث
عن التي
تعثر وساطه المصريه تعثرت ما الذي ادى الى
تعثر هذه الهدنه والوساطه وكيف ممكن ان
يتغير المشهد بالساعات المقبله
هناك الان بدات حتى داخل اسرائيل انتقادات
لاداء الحكومه على حياء طبعا من قبل
جنرالات سابقوا سابقين عمليا يقولون بان
اسرائيل ربما تكون غامره اكثر من اللزوم
في هذه العمليه بمعنى كان هناك عمليات
اغتيال بالنسبه لاسرائيل منذ البدايه هي
فاجات في هذا الموضوع تستطيع ان تسوق ذلك
انجازا فيما ان الجهاد الاسلامي ضرب تل
ابيب وما الى ذلك يستطيع ان يسوق ان ذلك
هو انجاز ايضا بالنسبه لحركه الجهاد
وبالتالي كانت الظروف مئاتيه امس لوقف
اطلاق النار لكن اسرائيل استمرت في
الاغتيالات ربما فيها ربح تكتيكي كما يقول
هؤلاء ولكن استراتيجيا قد تورط اسرائيل
الان في دوامه اكبر وقد تنضم حماس بشكل
اقوى الى هذه المواجهه وتتوسع الى حرب
شامله وبالتالي اسرائيل تجاوزت نقطه معينه
في هذه المواجهه والان باتت ترد عمليا على
المبادره من قبل الفصائل وهذا عمليا قد
يكون مشكله بالنسبه للاسرائيليين طبعا مع
وجود الان قتيل واطلاق هذه الصواريخ
اللافت هذه الليله بان هناك مشهدا عبثي
مشهد عبثي في تل ابيب يجري الان بينما
نتحدث عشرات الالاف في حفل موسيقي في
الخلاء عمليا وهذا غير مفهوم من اقر ذلك
بالنسبه هناك صاروخ صاروخ
عمليا ليس مفهوما من اقر هذا الموضوع في
هذه الحال لان كميه هائله من الناس في
مكان
نعم هذا الصاروخ انفجر فوقنا اضطررت طبعا
الى الانسحاب قليلا زياده نتمنى ان تتوخل
حذر يعني سنترك الان
معك هذا الصاروخ هذا الصاروخ سقط عمليا
بالقرب منا طبعا
على سلامتكم كنت اقول
لا مشكله طبعا لا انا رايت اين ذهب
وبالتالي
لا لا انا رايت اين ذهب وبالتالي عدت الى
هنا عمليا اقول بان هذه
هذا التصعيد بالنسبه لاسرائيل هناك نقطه
تجاوزتها ان كنا نتحدث عن تل ابيب وجود
عشرات الالاف عمليا في مناطق في الخلاء
وسط تل ابيب في حفل موسيقي عمليا هذا
الامر جرى انتقاده ايضا من مستوطني هذه
المنطقه عمليا هناك اجراءات صارمه فيما ان
تل ابيب تتصرف بشكل مختلف الان ان هناك
انفجارات هناك غارات اسرائيليه على شمال
قطاع غزه تنفذ تباعا بعد هذه الرشاقات
الصاروخيه المتعاقبه عمليا التي تطلقها
الفصائل الفلسطينيه تجاه مستوطنات الغلاف
وكما سبق وقلت قبل قليل وصلت الى ريشون
والى حلون اي الى وسط اسرائيل مجددا كما
قلنا في معظم الرشقات بات الان ضرب لوسط
اسرائيل
لمنطقه وسط اسرائيل منطقه تل ابيب هذا
ربما يكون الصوره بالساعات المقبله شكرا
لك زياد حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
من غزه مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحافه احمد
حرب احمد كيف هي الصوره من هناك
خصوصا اننا نتحدث عن اطلاق كثيف للصواريخ
تجاه يعني اسرائيل والمستوطنات
الاسرائيليه
يعني سوره المشهد قائم
الفلسطينيه تقوم الان باطلاق ابوابل من
الصواريخ باتجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
المحاديه للقطاع في الصواريخ وصلت حسب
الاعلام الاسرائيلي الى
عام وزكيم وغيرها من البلدات الاسرائيليه
وهناك صاروخ فقط بالقرب من من تل ابيب
بمعنى ان الفصائل الفلسطينيه وحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي
تواصل لاطلاق الصواريخ ردا على عمليه
الاغتيال التي حصلت قبل ساعات لنائب
الوحده الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس وايضا
ليلا كان هناك اغتيال لمسؤول الوحده
الصاروخيه في شقته في خان يونس الجنوب
القطاع في بيان للمناطق باسم سرايا القدس
ابو حمزه اكد فيه بان
الحركه والسرايا القدس مصممه على مواجهه
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه وانها سوف
تواصل اطلاق الصواريخ تجاه البلدات
الاسرائيليه المحاديه
للقطاع الوضع في القطاع هو حاله التوتر
قائمه والتصريف قائم الى
المتعلق يعني
الميدانيه تقابل ايضا هناك بالتزامن
تحركات دبلوماسيه يجريها الوسيط المصري
والاممي منذ ساعات الصباح اليوم كان هناك
وفد يرسه رئيس الدائره السياسيه في حركه
الجهاد الاسلامي محمد الهندي الذي وصل الى
القاهره وتباحث مع المخابرات المصريه
احمد على كل حال سنعود يعني نتابع معكم مع
الزملاء الصوره من غزه وايضا من
المستوطنات شكرا لك على هذه الرساله
[موسيقى]
في السودان وبينما تستمر المحادثات بين
وفدي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
في جده بواساطه سعوديه امريكيه لوقف
القتال يبدو ان التفاؤلا حذرا بات يلوح في
الافق على الرغم من الاشتباكات العنيفه
طبعا التي شهدتها العاصمه الخرطوم خلال
الساعات الماضيه الناطق باسم العمليه
السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف اكد على ايجابيه
الاجواء خلال مباحثات جد قائلا ان
المفاوضات تسير بشكل جيد وهناك اراده
للتواصل الاتفاق واشنطن عادت ولوحت بعصا
العقوبات على طرفي الصراع العسكريين في
السودان اذا لم يتوقف النزاع بينهما وجاء
ذلك على لسان وكيله وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه التي اكدت بانه رغم التفاؤل
بالمباحثات لكنهم يدرسون ايضا الاطراف
التي يمكن استهدافها بالعقوبات ما لم
يوافق الفصيله المتحاربان على ذلك ياتي
ذلك مشاهدينا فيما التحذيرات الدوليه من
تدهور الاوضاع الامنيه والصحيه والغذائيه
بشكل خطير واتساع طبعا رقعه القتال بين
طرفي النزاع الى حرب شامله فضلا طبعا عن
تنامي اعداد اللاجئين
[موسيقى]
وسط المعارك وتحت مرمى النيران لم تتوقف
ندى موسى ورفقائها من مواصله عمليات
الاعداد الخاص برياضه العاب القوى هنا
بمدينه نيالا ولايه جنوب دارفور غربيه
السودان المعارك وتوترات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع لم تمنعهم من التمسك بحلمهم
اعمل انجاز في الولايه في السودان عام
يعني اكون لعبه دوليه في السودان وخارج
السودان والله رغم المشاكل دي احنا ما
وقفنا من تماريننا مواصلين في التمارين
رغم الضغوطات الحاصله دي شغالين فيها
اربعه اعوام كامله ظل الفريق يواصل
الاعدادات بهدف المشاركه في اولمبياد
باريس هذا العام المدرب المشرف عليهم
يتمنى عوده الاوضاع الى طبيعتها لاستكمال
المشوار احنا الان يعني في مرحله
اولمبيادة باريس اقتربت والان اسلم بامور
بازمه ان احنا كنا حسب التخطيط بتاعنا
هناخد
بقدر ما نملك بقدر ما نملك من مجهود رياضي
نحاول ننمي الوطن ما بنحاول ندمر الوطن
على الرغم مما تمر به البلاد المصاعب يظل
الحلم قائما من اجل صناعه واقع افضل
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
رؤساء اركان الجيوش الاوروبيه الى زياده
الامدادات العاجله الى كييف
[موسيقى]
نستكمل مشاهدينا من الانتخابات التركيه
فقبل ثلاثه ايام فقط من الانتخابات يعلن
احد منافسي اردوغان انسحابا مفاجئا من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه محرم انشاء اعلن
رسميا انه قرر الانسحاب من السباق ويعد
انجي واحد من ابرز او من اربعه مرشحين
للرئاسه الى جانب
اردوغانو وايضا وقالت وكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه ان هذه الخطوه قد تمهد للمعارضه
الفوز في اول جوله اما اردوغان فعبر عن
حزنه على انسحاب احد منافسيه وفقا لرئاسات
التركيه
لا تتركوا للمعارضه اي اعذار والا عندما
يخسرون الانتخابات سيضعون كل اللوم علينا
في صباح اليوم التالي ادعو جميع المنتمين
لحزب البلد ان يقوموا بالتصويت وانا اعلن
انسحابي من الترشح للرئاسه
[موسيقى]
في مقابلات خاصه لقناه العربيه مع زميل
طاهر بركه مع زعيم حزب الوطن اليسري دوجو
برينجك قال فيها بان اردوغان متذبذب في
مواقفه حياله امريكا وغيرها من الملفات
وان عملك مستشار للسياسه الخارجيه لا يعني
بانه
مستشاردوغان بل هو يعمل قد قوه مؤثره
خارجيه
اردوغان يتذبذب ولا يتخذ موقفا ثابتا حيال
الامبرياليه الامريكيه فعندما ننظر الى
سياسته الخارجيه في سوريا نجد ان هناك
اتجاهين داخل حزب العداله والتنميه
الاتجاه الاول ينحاز الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والثاني يؤيد الانحياز الى
سوريا والعراق وايران وروسيا ونحن ها هنا
نتبع سياسه حازمه وثابته ونسعى الى
التاثير على الرئيس اردوغان لسنا مستشارين
له لكن نحن قوه مؤثره في السياسه التركيه
وندافع عن الصداقه مع الدول العربيه
والشرق اوسطيه
اكثر من 70 ساعه تفصلنا عن معرفه من سيحكم
تركيا والرئيس التركي اردوغان يواجه اصعب
معركه انتخابيه بعدما وحدت ست احزاب
معارضه قواها لخوض الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه ضده وكشف هنا استطلاع للراي
نقلته رويترز ان زعيم المعارضه
يتقدم على منافسه اردوغان
كما نشاهد هنا رجب اردوغان بثلاثه واربعين
بالمئه
49.3% بينما طبعا كما شاهدنا هنا
49.3% في حال لم يتمكن المرشحه الرئاسي من
الحصول على اكثر من نصف الاصوات في الرابع
عشر من مايو سوف تعاد الانتخابات بعد
اسبوعين من تاريخ هذا الاحد وكى يتمكن اي
حزب من دخول البرلمان ذي اس 600 مقعد
يتعين عليه الحصول على 7% من اصوات
الناخبين او ان يكون جزءا من تحالف يحصل
على هذه النسبه اما الناخبون الاتراك
فسيصوتون للقوائم الحزبيه وليس للمرشحين
طبعا بموجب نظام التمثيل النسبي الموجود
الان في تركيا ومن ثم فان عدد المقاعد
تحدده الاصوات التي تمنح لكل حزب وليس
للتحالفات وفقا ايضا للقانون التركي
في السباق الرئاسي التركي اقتصر المشهد
على متنافسين رئيسيين هما الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان والمعارض كمال كالجدار
اوغلو لم يسبق ان اعتبر اوغلو محطه امال
المعارضه لكنه استطاع في النهايه الانتصار
بالقبول به كمرشح مشترك
التفاف لم يكن برضى الاغلبيه لكنه تم رغبه
من احزاب المعارضه بمواجهه اردوغان فاضطرت
لتوحيد صفوفها بتجمع سته احزاب تحت ما سمي
الطاوله السداسيه قبل ان تعيد تسميه
التحالفها تحالف الامه بقياده كالجدار
اوغلو صاحب الكتله الاكبر في البرلمان
وزعيم اكبر تحالف معارض كلجدار اوغلو لم
يفوز باي انتخابات ضد اردوغان منذ تولي
الاخير السلطه عام 2002 وواجهها ضغوطا
لثنيه عن الترشح للرئاسه رغم ذلك وجدت
المعارضه نفسها مضطره للقبول بالامر
الواقع لهدف واحد الاطاحه باردوغان تغيير
النظام السياسي
اقتصاديه مختلفه جذريا والاهم تبني نهج
مختلف كليا عنه في السياسه الخارجيه
اختياره كل جدار اوغلو مرشحا مشتركا بعد
خلافات عميقه قد يهدد بتفجير ازمات في اي
لحظه لذا سيجد كلجدار اوغلو نفسه امام
صراع قديم جديد فحلفاء اليوم هم اعداء
الامس القواعد الحزبيه المحافظه الداعمه
له السعاده الديمقراطيه والتقدم المستقبل
لديها عداء تاريخي ما احزاب اليسار ممثله
بحزب الشعب الجمهوري ورئيسه
اعداءه كالجدار اوغلو ليسوا فقط من احزاب
المعارضه لكنهم داخل حزبه خسرته
الانتخابات الرئاسيه قد تفجر غضبا عارما
وتتسبب بتفتت اصوات المعارضه خاصه وان
كالجدار اوغلو حاول ان يتقرب من المحافظين
رغم ايدولوجيا الحزب العلمانيه وضم
بقوائمه حلفاء السابق لاردوغان امر اثار
حفيظه قواعد حزبيه المعار ضه واثار مخاوفه
من تاثير سلبي على المعدل التصويطي للحزب
وحظوظ الطاوله السداسيه
معنى مشاهدينا من اسطنبول عبر سكايب
الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو استاذ
فراس سابدا يعني من موضوع تقسيم الاصوات
الذي كان هناك تخوف كبير منه لدى المعارضه
خصوصا بانه سيصب نهايه المطاف لصالح
اردوغان اليوم مع انسحاب زعيم حزب الوطن
القومي العلماني
انجي كيف
سنتوقع او سنرى النتائج في الجوله الاولى
نعم يعني حقيقه هو انسحابه ممكن ان نقول
ان الاصوات التي ربما كانت ستذهب اليه
الاغلب وهذا الترجيح الاكبر هنا ان تذهب
الى السيد كمال كونها يعني
العقليه تقريبا متقاربه وكونه كان هو في
هذا الحزب حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى ان
انشقى عنه في بعد الانتخابات السابقه
والهزيمه التي تعرض لها وخصوصا ايضا هو
المناطق التي يعني تشهد له او الذي هي
ربما تدعمه بشكل او باخر هي نفس المناطق
التي المعارضه فيها قويه اكثر من الائتلاف
الحاكم لذلك انا اظن ان الاصوات التي كانت
ستذهب الى اضافه الى ربما بعض اصوات
الشبابيه لان لديه ايضا
اصوات شبابيه في الداخل الاصوات الشبابيه
ستذهب الى كمان ايضا المرشح الثالث اتحدث
هنا عن ما يسمى بالمرشح القومي المتطرف
اوجان ايضا يعني من المعروف بان الاسواق
هم من معجبين به او من سيصوتون له هم
اصوات شبابيه اليوم مع انسحاب اول مرشح
وبقاء هذا المرشح من سيستطيع جذب الاصوات
الشبابيه نتحدث عن يعني كتله كبيره جدا
ستصوت لاول مره
بالانتخابات
وهناك يعني العين كلها على هذه الكتله
يعني انا اتوقع بالنسبه للسيد سنان هو
يعني اضعف بكثير من ان ينافس كلا الطرفين
ليس لديه تلك
لنقل الخلفيه المشهوره على الاقل سياسيا
الشباب ايضا الشباب في تركيا اظن يعني هم
متنوعون اكثر من مساله الخطاب القومي
وخصوصا الذي كان يعني لديه بعض الخطابات
القويه التي حتى بين داخل التركي اثارت
بعض المشاكل ورفضت حتى من بعض الاحزاب
منها الاحزاب المعارضه وفي ذلك ربما سيحسب
على تلك
المغادرات
العنصريه نوعا ما ولكن هذا لا يعني انه
شخصيه محترمه لديه شخص يعني انجذاب لبعض
الاشخاص ولكن مستحيل هذا رايي ان يزاحم
مثلا السيد كمال الذي لديه خبره قديمه
لديه الحزب الاكبر في المعارضه لديه
التجمع
الحزبي السياسي المتنوع في هذا السياق
ايضا لديه عنصرين قويين يعني وايضا ليس
فقط تنوع الحزبي هو يعتمد على السيد امام
اوغلو والسيد منصوريه كونهما لديهما هذا
عندما نتحدث عن هؤلاء حوالي خمسه يعني
ملايين ناخب هذه الكتله الشبابيه التي
ستصوت لاول مره مع انسحاب المرشح الثالث
بقي مرشحين رئيسيين اضافه الى اوغان الذي
تحدثنا عنه لمن ستصب الاصوات اليوم هل
ستكون لصالح اوغلو وبالتالي هل نتحدث عن
جوله واحده او جوله اي
الحقيقه هذا السؤال فعلا هو سؤال اللحظه
في في تركيا
يعني الاستطلاعات الراي طبعا توقفت ولكن
ما يتداوله هنا الاعلاميين من الاصدقاء
ايضا ان هناك نسبه طفيفه لصالح كمالك لكن
يعني هذا لا يؤكد على انه سيفوز لان ايضا
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان لديه كتله صلبه في
الداخل التركي لديه ولايات كثيره ستصوت
لصالحي طبعا لان الفرق ربما الاصوات اضافه
الى حزب الذي كان اسمه الشعب الديمقراطي
وسمى نفسه
اليسار والخضر هو سيصوت اظن لصالح سيد
كمال مقابله للنقل الحزب الكردي او تجمع
الاحزاب اليساريه الكرديه سيقابل التجمع
الاحزاب
اليمين او الاسلاميه الكرديه لصالح
اردوغان هذا هو الصراع القائم الحقيقه بين
الطرفين على
[موسيقى]
يترقب محمد الانتخابات التركيه وسط مخاوف
يعيشها كباقي اللاجئين من انعكاسات قد
تؤثر على لجوئهم ووجودهم في تركيا وذلك مع
تلويح الاحزاب التركيه بملف اللاجئين في
حملاتهم الانتخابيه في حاله ترقب وغير
مسبوقا بصراحه نتيجه الانتخابات التركيه
بتعرف نحن صرنا ورقه ضغط لجميع الاحزاب
التركيه سواء بسيطات الاحزاب المعارضه او
سيطره حزب العداله والتنميه ففي هنا في
عندك عوده طبيعيه وعوده اجباريه وحاليا
عايشين حول الترقب نحن وجميع السوريين في
خوف في خوف مو طبيعي الناس خايفه ترجع على
سوريا
الخلاف التركي التركي حول التعامل مع ملف
اللاجئين السوريين ليس وليد اليوم فقد
ازدادت حملات التحريض على السوريين في
الفتره الماضيه من قبل شخصيات واحزاب
مختلفه لم يفصل الجدار الحدودي مع تركيا
مخ السوريين من انعكاسات الانتخابات
التركيه عليهم فالاجئون في تركيا
والنازحون في الشمال السوري يحبسون
انفاسهم لمعرفه ماء سيتغير حالهم بعد
الانتخابات
يرى السوريون في الشمال السوري ان نتائج
الانتخابات التركيه لابد ان تنعكس على
الملف السوري بشكل عام وليس على وجود
اللاجئين في تركيا فحسب كعلاء الذي يترقب
نتائج الانتخابات وما ستحمله من انعكاسات
على الشمال السوري وعلى اخيه وعائلته
اللاجئين في تركيا نتمنى نتمنى انه انه
مالات الانتخابات التركيه بتكون ايجابيه
وتصب في خانه مصلحه السوري سواء انا
متواجد في تركيا او نتواجد في الداخل
السوري ونتمنى من نفس الوقت انه نتائج هاي
الانتخابات تثمر عند عند فتح افق جديد في
الملف السوري كونه في حاله استع صاء وكونه
في حاله انسداد وانغلاق على مستوى السياسي
وغيره وغيره حاله التدافع السياسي بين
الاحزاب التركيه وطريقه تعاملها مع الملف
السوري دفعت السوريين في الشمال السوري
واللاجئين في تركيا للميول الى حزب
العداله والتنميه والرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
محمد الاشقر العربيه الحدود السوريه
التركيه
في الملف الحرفي اوكرانيا قال قائد قوات
فاجنر يفقي ان القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول
خنقهم في بخموت وتهاجم محور محمود وتنجح
في ذلك لافتا الى ان الجيش الاوكراني بدا
هجوم الربيع بعدما تلقى التدريب والمعدات
اللازمه
بالنسبه للهجوم المضاد
الهجوم المضاد يمضي بسرعه وعلى قدم وساق
تهاجم وحدات من الجيش الاوكراني محور
باخموت وللاسف هم ينجحون بذلك كما ذكرت
مرات عده فان خطه القوات الاوكرانيه
تتمحور في خنقنا نحن نحاول خنقهم وهم
يحاولون كذلك هم يحتاجون اولا الى التخلص
من عناصر فاجنر في محور بخموت ثم التوجه
بكامل الامكانيات الى زباروجيا وبريانسكو
بالقرود ولذلك فان الهجوم الاوكرانيه بدا
لقد حصلوا بالفعل على المعدات العسكريه
اللازمه وعلى التدريب اللازم عناصر فاجنر
تواصل مهامها القتاليه رغم عدم وجود
الذخائر والدعم الذي وعدت به وزاره الدفاع
ومع ترقب بانطلاق الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاد قال الرئيس الاوكراني
بلاده بحاجه الى مزيد من الوقت لشل هجوم
مضاد ضد القوات الروسيه في الوقت الذي
ينتظر الجيش تسلم المساعدات العسكريه
الموعوده واضف كان القوات التي تم تدريبها
من قبل الناتو اصبحت جاهزه للقتال لكن
الجيش لا يزال بحاجه الى معدات اكثر بما
في ذلك العربات المدرعه الرئيس الاوكراني
اشار الى امكانيه المضي بشن الهجوم لكن
هناك مخاوف مدنيه وعسكريه وعليه سننتظر
بعض الوقت مشاهدا في الوقت عينه على عدم
التخلي عن اي جزء من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
لروسيا وحول دعم الامريكي قال زينسكي
انكياف لا تزال تتمتع بدعم الحزبين في
الكونجرس الامريكيه
اعلنا وزير الدفاع البريطاني ان بلاده
قررت التبرع بصواريخ بعيده المدى الى
اوكرانيا
ان المملكه المتحده قررت التبرع بصواريخ
ستورم شادو بعيده المدى الى اوكرانيا هي
صواريخ تقليديه قادره على الضربات الدقيقه
وتكمل مجموعه الصواريخ بعيده المدى التي
تم ارسالها لاوكرانيا
ارسال هذه الصواريخ يمنح اوكرانيا الفرصه
للدفاع عن نفسها ضد الوحشيه الروسيه خصوصا
استهداف البنيه التحتيه المدنيه المتعمد
وهو ما ينتهك القانون الدولي اوكرانيا يجب
ان يكون لها الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد
ذلك استخدام سيسمح لاوكرانيا بدفع القوات
الروسيه بعيدا عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه
قبل ذلك انتقدت رئاسه الروسيه لكريم خطط
بريطانيا لتزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده
المدى فقال المتحدث باسم كريم ان هذه
الخطوه التي وصفها بالسلبيه ستتطلب ردا
مناسبا من الجيش الروسي وفي تصريحات هي
الاولى من نوعها قال بس كوب ان العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا صعبه ومعقده
للغايه ولم تحقق الاهداف بعد
في هذا الخطاب قبل عام ونيف كان بوتين
عازما على تدمير من وصفهم بالنازيين الجدد
في اوكرانيا واليوم يقول الكرملين ان
العمليه صعبه ومعقده للغايه
فوفقا للمتحدث باسم الكريم
فان العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لم تحقق كل اهدافها هذه المهمه تحققت
جزئيا لكن لازلنا بعيدين عن تنفيذها
بالصوره كامله ترون القصف بواسطه رجمات
الصواريخ قصف دونيتسك والمدن الاخرى
مستمره لذلك هناك حاجه الى ابعاد العدو
الى مسافه كبيره ولذلك ان العمليه ستستمر
في الوقت الذي كان يتحدث فيه بيسكو تقول
اوكرانيا انها حققت تقدما على الارض في
باخموت اهم بقعه من الصراع بين الجانبين
ومدينه المعركه الاطول في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بحسب قائد القوات البريه في
الجيش الاوكراني اوكسندر سيسكي فان القوات
الاوكرانيه شنت هجوما مضادا في باخموت
واجبرت القوات الروسيه على التراجع في بعض
الاماكن الى مسافه تصل
فحتى مقاتلوا فاغنر وفقا لسيرسكي استبدلوا
في بعض الاماكن بوحدات من الجيش النظامي
الروسي وهي اقل استعدادا العمليه الخاصه
كما وصفها اجبرت روسيا على شنها ولم تكن
خيارا بسبب ما ارتكبتها الدول الغربيه من
الاشياء السيئه والاخطاء فالغرب وفقا لرجل
الكرملين خدع روسيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي من خلال توسيع البنيه التحتيه
والعسكريه لحلف الناتو باتجاه الحدود
الروسيه حدود شنت موسكو حربا من اجل
تامينها لكنها باتت عرضه للاستهداف اكثر
رائد المصطفى العربيه
دعا الممثل السامي لشؤون السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل رؤساء
اركان الجيوش الاوروبيه الى زياده
الامدادات العاجله الى كيف من الاحتياطات
الحاليه وكشف بورا الان الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعتزم تدريب 30 الف جندي اوكراني كما
سيوفر الاتحاد مليون وحده الذخيره من عيار
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
مدرسه في كوريا الشماليه تستخدم افلام
ديزني لتعليم اللغه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال السفير السعودي لدى
اليمن محمد الجابر ان الحكومه والحوثيين
ابدى جديه للسلام لكن من المستحيل التنبؤ
بموعد اجراء محادثات مباشره واضاف الجابر
ان هناك تفاؤلا تجاه ايجاد مخرج في اسرع
وقت ممكن واشار الى ان السعوديه تعتبر
نفسها اكثر من وسيط يحاول تسهيل اتفاق بين
الحكومه والحوثيين
[موسيقى]
تطورات متسارعه تشهدها باكستان عنوان هذه
التطورات اعتقال ومحاكمه رئيس الوزراء
الباكستانيه السابق عمران خان امام
المحكمه العليا التي اوصت بالافراج عنه
بعد امتثاله اليوم معتبره اي المحكمه
العليا بباكستان اعتقال جهاز مكافحه
الفساد لعمران خان امرا خاطئا رئيس
الوزراء الباكستاني السابق قال في
الافادته للمحكمه العليا انه جرى اختطافهم
من محكمه اسلام اباد مؤكدا تعرضه للضرب
اثناء اعتقاله وطلبت السلطات الباكستانيه
المحكمه العليا وعمران خان بمطالبه انصاره
البقاء سلميين والتنديد باعمال الشغب فيما
تواجه البلاد اضطرابات واسعه في الشوارع
وشهد هنا مشاهدينا انصار عمران خان يرقصون
قرب مبنى المحكمه احتفالا بقرار الافراج
عنه الا انه ميزال قيد الاعتقال لدى
السلطات الباكستانيه طبعا السلطات
الباكستانيه واجهت شغب واحتجاجات انصار
خان بمزيد من الاعتقالات بصفوف المحتاجين
وايضا قاده بحزب رئيس الوزراء السابق هذه
الاحتجاجات تسببت كما نرى هنا بالصور
اضرار وحرائق في الممتلكات العامه وخاصه
من بين هذه الممتلكات مبنى لازاعه للاذاعه
الباكستانيه ومراكز للشرطه ومركبات حكوميه
وخاصه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من اسلام اباد عبد الرحمن
المزيني مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن كيف هي
الصوره من هناك وهل يعني الاشتباكات ما
زالت مستمره
نعم هناك حاله من الابتهاج والفرحه عمه
اوساط انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان بعد صدور قرار المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا ببطلان اعتقاله
والافراج عنه الى حين مثوله يوم غد الجمعه
امام محكمه السبابات العليا لاستكمال
الاجراءات التي توقفت عندها المحاكمه
بتاريخ التاسع من هذا الشهر من المتوقع ان
يقدم الفريق القانوني لامران خان طلبا الى
محكمه استماد العليا للحصول على كفاله
مؤقته من ضد الاعتقال اود الاشاره هنا الى
ان هناك التصريحات التي صدرت عن الحكومه
وعن حزب الانصاف لا يبدو ان هناك
نهايه قريبه لهذه الازمه
حزب الانصار بزعامه عمران خان دعا انصاره
للت الى اسامه بعد
ابداع دعمهم وتضامنهم مع رئيس وزراء
السابق عمران خان وانتظار كلمه او خطاب
لرئيس وزراء السابق عمران خان بعد جلسه
المحاكمه يوم غد من جانبها هناك حاله من
لنقل من الغضب داخل الاوساط الحكوميه بشان
القرار الصادر عن المحكمه العليا
الدستوريه كان هناك انتقاد للقرارات
القرار الصادر عن المحكمه
واعتبار ان عمران خان حظي بمعامله تفضيليه
وحديث عن ان هناك معايير مزدوجه يتم
التعامل بها مع عمران خان بالنظر الى سجل
القضاء مع قاده الاحزاب المشاركين في
الحكومه الذين سبق ان قام مكتب المحاسبه
باعتقال بعضهم لاكثر من 90 يوم على ذمه
التحقيق في قضايا فساد
وزير الداخلي ه الباكستاني رانا ثناء الله
في تصريح له قال انه في حال حصل عمران خان
على كفاله ضد الاعتقال فانه سوف يتم اعاده
اعتقاله فورا انتهاء هذه الكفاله اذا ربما
هناك هدوء نسبي بعض الشيء هذا ما كنت اسال
عنه خان متهم او لديه اكثر من ملف اليوم
ليس فقط الفساد التعامل مع الخارج التامر
على الدوله وما الى هناك وبالتالي غدا
يعني هل نتحدث عن افراج مؤقت ومن بعد
الادعاء عليه بملفات جديده ام ماذا
وفق قرار المحكمه العليا فقد امرت بعدم
اعتقال اي متهم ومن بينهم عمران خان ولكن
القرار عام بانه لا يجب اعتقال اي متهم
يسلم نفسه الى العداله داخل
مقر المحاكمه او محيطها الا بعد اتباع
الاجراءات
القانونيه المتبعه في حال رفض قاضي
المحكمه منح كفاله مؤقته لامران خان
فتلقائيا
بامكان مكتب المحاسبه الوطني اعاده
اعتقاله لكن في حال منحه كفاله مؤقته
وعاده تكون لبضعه ايام
بضعه اسابيع فعلى الحكومه ان تنتظر في هذه
القضيه تحديدا الى انتهاء هذه المده التي
ستمنحها او سيمنحها قاضي المحكمه لكن
مقابل ذلك هناك كما اشرت عده قضايا وهناك
مذكرات اعتقال جاهزه لاعتقان عمران خان
لكن لم يتم اعتقاله في محيط المحكمه ربما
اثناء عودته الى منزله في مدينه لاهور او
ربما بعد بضعه ايام عبد الرحمن باختصار لو
سمحت قبل ان اختم عمران خان اين هو الان
يعني بهذه اللحظه موقوف اين
وفق المحكمه الدستوريه العليا عمران خان
ليس موقوفا ليس معتقلا وليس سجينا لكنه
لسبب الاجراءات الامنيه فهو تحت حصانه
المحكمه العليا وتم اعادته الى بيت
الضيافه التابع لمجمع الشرطه هنا في
العاصمه حيث يمكث هناك وسمحت له السلطات
او المحكمه بلقاء ما بين عشره الى 12 من
مرافقيه او انصاره في داخل هذا
وبالتالي هو يعني نوع من الاعتقال ولكن
ليس داخل مركز الشرطه انما بيت الضيافه
وتحت تحت يعني منظار قبل امنيه شكرا لك من
اسلام اباد عبد الرحمن المزيني مراسل
العربيه
[موسيقى]
مسلسل وبايدن ترامب لا ينتهي والسبب
السباق الرئاسي نحو البيت الابيض حيث لا
يترك الرجلين اي فرصه للنيل من بعضهما هذه
المره بايدن علق على ترامب بعدما كرر
الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب اقواله حول
حادثه اقتحام انصاره مبنى الكابيتال في
السادس من يناير عام 2021 في مقابله لشبكه
سي ان ان بايدن بدا وكانه يراقب عن كثب
خصمه تراب وغرد ردا عليه قائلا لا انقياء
بين مثيري الشغب انتهت القصه مرفقا هذه
التغريده بمقطع فيديو كما نشاهد هنا
ونصف هذا المقطع لمقابله من ترامب والاخر
للقطات العنف امام مبنى الكابيتول يوم
السادس من يناير في اشاره منه طبعا الى ما
فعله انصار ترامب في ذلك التوقيت وفي ذلك
اليوم ولكن
غير عادته لم يرد ترامب على بايدن ولكن
ثبات مواقفه بشان تزوير نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاخيره والحرب في اوكرانيا خطفت
الاضواء من جديد بعدما اكد مره اخرى انه
سيوقف هذه الحرب خلال اربع انواع وعشرين
ساعه في حال تم انتخابه وانه لن يكون او
لو كان هو رئيسا لما كانت تلك الحرب
اندلعت من اصله وفي حال انتخابه لولايه
جديده سيعمل على تسويه لا يخسر فيها احد
من خلال التفاوض مباشره بين الرئيسين
بوتين
طبعا ايضا هنا
[موسيقى]
قال برلمانيون جمهوريون ان عددا من افراد
عائله الرئيس جو بايدن وشركاء له تلقوا
صفقات غامضه بنحو عشره ملايين دولار من
شركات اجنبيه بينها صينيه ورومانيه وتندرج
الاتهامات في اطار حمله طويله تستهدف
الاعمال المثيره للجدل بايدن ناجل الرئيس
الديمقراطي الذي يتهمه اليمين باستغلال
اسم والدته ومعارفه عندما كان بايدن نائبا
للرئيس باراك اوباما لابرام عقود مثيره
للشك في دول عديده
في الولايات المتحده ايضا استعدت الاجهزه
الامنيه لاستقبال المهاجرين من الحدود
المكسيكيه بحجدهم ل 24 الف عنصر وذلك عقب
رفع الاجراءات عن قانون تايتل فورتيتو
المثير للجدل الذي اقره الرئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامب بحجه محاربه انتشار كورونا
[موسيقى]
في رقم قياسي جديد وصل عدد النازحين حول
العالم الى اكثر من 70 مليون نازح اضطروا
الى ترك منازلهم قصرا يعود هذا لزياده
الصراعات والحروب والكوارث الطبيعيه وفق
تقرير امم فلنتابع
الظرف ذاته والطريق ربما مسيره النزوح عن
الديار تتلاقى تفاصيلها عالميا جلب ما
تيسر لهم ووسيله نقل ان توفرت
اعداد النزوح وصلت مداها عام 2022
وتخطت 71 مليونا في رقم قياسي جديد
ازمه تتبع اخرى عام فتح ذراعيه اما للحرب
او الكوارث الطبيعيه العاملين الاساسيين
لزياده اعداد الفارين
ارتفاع بنسبه 20% بعد هجره جماعيه ضربت
اوكرانيا في حربها بلغ عددهم 17 مليونا
وايضا فيضانات باكستان اغرقت البلاد
بثمانيه ملايين نازح داخليا
العام الماضي ولا ثقيلا على افريقيا
الصراعات المتتاليه ضعفت اعداد المغتربين
قصرا افريقيا جنوب الصحراء الاكثر تضررا
وصلت اعدادهم الى 16 مليون و500 الف شخص
10 دول اخرى يرزخ فيها ثلاثه ارباع الفرين
داخليا ابرزها سوريا وافغانستان واليمن
واثيوبيا وفق تقرير مشترك لمنظمات امميه
عداد الفرين لن يتوقف وفق تقديرات امميه
هم متقارب ينتظرون فرجا لم ياتي قريبا
ربما في عام حالي بصراعات متفاقمه غذاء
السالم العربيه
[موسيقى]
فيلم فروزن وبلغته الام الانجليزيه يدخل
الى مدرسه في كوريا الشماليه كي يتمكن
الطلاب من تعلم اللغه الانجليزيه المحظوره
مع متحدثيها الاصليين في تلك البلاد وفق
ما كشفته صحيفه تايمز البريطانيه
احد افلام ديزني حقق نجاحا عالميا عام
2013 اخترته المدرسه الكوريه كي تسهل على
الطلاب استخدام اللغه الانجليزيه ونطقها
جيدا مما يشير الى التاثير الثقافي
الامريكيه على المجتمع في البلاد زعيم
كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ اون كان شجع على
اجراء تغييرات بالمناهج الدراسيه خلاف
طبعا للقرارات السابقه التي حضرت فيها
استخدام طبعا سلطات البلاد المواطنين من
مشاهده افلام او الاستمتاع او الاستماع
الى موسيقى غير محليه
في الختام مشاهدينا تذكير بابرز العناوين
اسرائيل تكثف غاراتها على قطاع غزه وتغتال
قياديا في حركه الجهاد وصواريخ الاخيره
تصل تل ابيب
اعداد هائله من المصابين
عادات كبيره جدا وخوف وهل تحضيرات الامميه
من تفشي او باخطيره في السودان جراء
الصراع العسكري وتفاؤل على صعيد المحادثات
في جده
قبل ثلاثه ايام من بدء الانتخابات انسحاب
مفاجئ لاحد منافسي اردوغان واستطلاع يرجح
انتصار اوغلو
باكستان تامر بالافراج مؤقتا عن عمران خان
والحكومه تطالبها بقرار يدين شغب انصاره
التاسع انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره والان الى 360 مع الزميله راويه
راويه مساء الخير وماذا لديك مساء الخير
ليال طبعا المزيد من التصعيد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وايضا
بملف السباق الرئاسي التركي انسحاب مرشح
قبل ايام من الانتخابات وملفات اخرى
تابعين تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات